hello everybody and welcome back back by
popular demand because I don't get views
otherwise I am doing another low level
design video I'm also switching up the
format a little bit this time so instead
of doing one in a code editor like last
time I'm actually opting to use
PowerPoint the reason for this is
because I don't like being a software
engineer and I prefer to be an
investment banker because that's all
they do so anyways without further Ado
let's go ahead and get into this so I
can crank this video out while my
roommate is taking a shower and we can
do the PowerPoint okay so the subject of
today's video is going to be doing the
low level design of a cache and
basically as we know because we've
talked about it plenty in systems design
but it's relevant even just on a single
Machine level a cache is really just a
key value store that's really useful for
storing the results of any recent
computation so you don't have to reuse a
bunch of CPU Cycles re-figuring out what
that result was so generally speaking
the functional requirements of a problem
like this is like we mentioned we want
some sort of key value store that's
going to allow us to put get and delete
keys and then in addition to that we
want to be able to evict certain Keys
based on a variety of different policies
when it is going to be the case that
basically you know we're out of storage
or out of capacity in our cache
so what's our design philosophy going to
be well this is where we kind of get
more into the object oriented design
part of things and generally we want our
cache to be able to be using many
different policies and potentially many
even different types of storage and as a
result of that something that's going to
come in very handy here is actually
interfaces we can use interfaces within
our cache to basically Define something
like I don't know a storage interface or
an eviction policy interface and as a
result of that it's going to allow us to
basically plug in many different types
of implementations for these things and
build many different types of caches and
that's going to be really helpful to us
in the future
so without further Ado let's actually go
ahead and get into our basic cache
interface because eventually we may even
want to be building multiple different
types of caches based on the types of
storage and eviction policies that we
use so let's imagine that we have some
cash class or an interface and generally
we know that we're going to have to take
in some sort of storage interface class
there's some sort of basically class
that implements the storage interface
some sort of eviction policy class and
some sort of capacity which is going to
be an integer just as a quick recap for
everyone that's not necessarily familiar
with the term interface the point is we
know that this cache is going to
absolutely implement the methods defined
below get put and delete but the way
that those methods are implemented may
be defined differently Additionally you
know I guess necessarily the cache
doesn't have to be an interface itself
but perhaps we can have classes that
extend the cash class where we have that
get put and delete defined a certain way
and then maybe depending on which type
of storage and eviction policy we're
using we can also add additional methods
that might give us additional
functionality so for example you know if
we were to use a hash map get input or
pretty straightforward but if we were to
use something like a tree map then maybe
we would want to be able to do like a
get ordered list of keys because that's
something you can really easily do with
a tree map and so again the using the
interface allows us to Plug and Play a
bunch of different types of storage
backends and also basically eviction
policies into our cash class and still
have the same exact functionality using
a bunch of different implementations
it's going to make this a lot more
extensible and maintainable and
additionally you know give us a lot more
flexibility in the future if we say want
to use I don't know a different type of
storage okay so let's go ahead and
quickly look into something like the
implementations for all of those methods
that we know we have to implement in the
cash class so the first one is going to
be to get and basically that's saying
you know for a given key get the
corresponding value all we're going to
do is call our eviction policy to
basically update the evictions according
to the key because for certain eviction
policies it's very important that you
know it takes this into account when
you're actually going to be getting a
key for example if we're using something
like least recently used we want to be
updating our lru eviction policy based
on the fact that we're actually getting
the corresponding value of a key and
then finally we're going to go into our
underlying story and we're going to call
the basically method of our storage to
say get the key and then moving onwards
we have our delete method and the
implementation for this is basically you
know if we're able to successfully
delete our key from the storage then we
want to also go ahead and tell our
eviction policy we no longer care to
keep track of this key you know if we're
going to ask our eviction policy what's
the next key to delete we no longer want
to be considering this current key as
something that could be deleted and then
we also want to be decrementing the size
okay and then finally for our put
operation we know that we're putting in
a key with certain value and the first
thing to do is say well okay if this
size is equal to basically the total
capacity of our cash we have to actually
go ahead and use our eviction policy to
figure out the next key to remove and we
can use that by calling a method get key
to evict on our eviction policy I'm just
assuming this exists right now but we
can go over what our eviction policies
look like in a little bit and then all
we're going to do from there is
basically say delete
our actual key we already just defined
delete in the previous slide and that's
going to also decrement the size there
then finally we want to again update
evictions because now we're adding this
key into our eviction policy and we want
to be able to handle that properly and
then finally we also want to be able to
go ahead and put
um basically the key and value into our
storage I'm noticing now that I did
forget to actually increment the size of
our cache by one so make sure to do that
as well
okay what are actually moving on some
possible basically storage class
implementations because the entire point
of making this an interface is so we can
talk about a few different types of key
value stores that we can actually use
for our storage so the first and obvious
one is going to be the hash map this is
really good because it's very simplistic
we know that we're going to be getting o
of one time complexities for element
accesses finds puts deletes gets all of
that good stuff however in addition to a
hash map there are other types of maps
that you can use and another one that we
can talk about is a tree map a tree map
is basically just a binary search tree
and the reason that the tree map is
really useful is in addition to you know
kind of having the keys and values as
part of that binary search tree meaning
that we're going to get logarithmic
complexity for inserts deletes all that
good stuff it also means that we can
really quickly get an ordering over all
the keys that's because doing certain
traversals of our binary search tree
basically from the bottom leftmost node
you know up to the top and then down to
the bottom rate is going to give us a
proper ordering over all of our keys and
so this is really useful for certain
types of cache implementations where you
know say we wanted to somehow return a
range of all of the keys in there so
that could be potentially really useful
it's not necessarily going to be the
case that we always want to be doing
this and again there are trade-offs in
terms of the time complexity but if
that's a feature that you want sometimes
having a sorted or ordered set is really
useful and then finally another
implementation is something like a
linked hash map where you're basically
using a hash map but you also have a
doubly linked list between the values of
the hash map and this is really useful
in determining an order of the keys of
that hashmap and basically you know in
terms of when they were inserted so the
first element inserted to the hash map
is then going to point to the second
element inserted into the hashmap and
this again allows us to have some
further functionality but again this
isn't too important just at the moment
what about possible eviction policies
well we've covered this a lot in systems
design but just to touch upon it again
we can always evict Keys randomly which
is easy enough we would just keep a set
of those keys and then you know we could
use a random class to just go ahead and
choose a random one every single time to
evict we could do fifo based off of a
queue and kind of um you know we would
just go ahead and delete the first
element in the queue this would also
probably have to deal with having some
sort of hash map pointing to the nodes
in the queue in the event that a key
were to be deleted so we could remove it
from something like the middle of the
queue same goes for lifo where it would
be something like a stack and then also
maybe some hash map pointing to the
nodes of the stack in the event that we
need to be able to basically delete one
from the middle of it and then also
another I guess less common policy is
lfu or least frequently used where
basically we would be using you know
every single time that a key is put or
updated or gotten or read we would
basically be incrementing the
corresponding count of how often that
key has been used so for example key
Jordan has been used three times uh you
know key Elon has been used six times so
Jordan is going to be removed if there's
a capacity of two and to do that this is
a really useful case where we would want
something like a priority queue and in
addition to that we would probably have
some hash map from the key name to a
node in the priority queue so that we
could really quickly update elements of
basically the priority queue and then
they could be shifted around as needed
and by having that sort of Min Heap we
can go ahead and really quickly find out
what the top element is and then remove
it from the Min Heap okay finally we
also have least recently used this is
the one that's probably most going to
actually be used in caches it's the most
common and as a result we're going to go
ahead and implement it to go ahead and
finish off this video because it seems
to be a pretty common extension question
of a problem like this and this is more
algorithmically focused but let's go
into it anyway okay so let's talk about
lru basically the general gist is we
have a bunch of keys the ones that have
been getting accessed and put and
updated a lot are going to be considered
recently used and the ones that haven't
are considered not recently used the one
that hasn't been accessed in the longest
time is going to be considered least
recently used and it should be the next
key to be evicted in the event of a
shortage of cash capacity so let's take
a look at an actual example of this
let's say we have these four Keys Elon
Larry Sergey and Jordan and we know that
Elon is least recently used Jordan is
the most recently used and basically
let's imagine the use case where we're
going to take one of these keys and
actually access it and then as a result
we're going to have to move that to the
most recently used so just because you
know we're always thinking about how we
can remove the least recently used Keys
one data structure that makes a lot of
sense here is something like a linked
list in the sense that to evict the
least recently used key we can just go
ahead and evict from the head and then
set the new head of the linked list to
be the next element from the head so we
would be setting Elon to Larry but what
if we had another use case which was
someone actually accessed the key value
pair where the key was Larry and now we
want to be able to move Larry to the end
of the linked list after Jordan so this
isn't as easy the reason for this being
that we don't actually know where the
node Larry is in the linked list so what
can we do well we could introduce
another data structure where we actually
have a hash map from the names of keys
to the node values themselves so now we
have a hash map from the string Larry to
actually the node containing the key
Larry in the lights list and so this is
going to help us a little bit in the
sense that now we know where Larry is
and we can move it to the end however we
also have to be able to delete Larry or
the node containing Larry from its
existing place in the linked list and as
a result of that it means that we're
going to need access to the node
containing Elon so what can we actually
do in order to do this well it's not
going to work very well with our
existing linked list because from the
node Larry we can only get to Sergey we
can't get to Elon in order to change its
next attribute so what we need to do
instead is use a doubly linked list so
now we're going to have to go ahead and
do that as you can see we have this
doubly linked list right here and in a
second I'm going to actually go ahead
and show off some pseudocode for how we
would go ahead and take a node Like
Larry and move it to the most recently
used part of our doubly linked list well
we would go ahead and do something like
this we would basically get the node
containing Larry from the hash map we
would say that Elon was the previous
element of the node containing Larry we
would set elon.next to be larry.next
which we know was the node containing
Sergey we would also have to change the
previous pointer of that Sergey node to
be Elon and then finally we would go
ahead and get the tail of the doubly
linked list which in this case would be
the node containing Jordan and then
finally we would set jordan.next to
Larry larry.previus to Jordan and then
also cancel out the larry.nex pointer so
we don't go ahead and have a cycle in
our doubly linked list finally
everything is in pretty good shape so
let's go ahead and look at the actual
pseudo code for this to tie it all
together
okay so we have our class for lru
eviction policy and basically all we're
going to have are our local variables
where we have some sort of doubly linked
list and also a hash map so let's say we
want to start out by being able to
delete a key from our eviction policy we
know that sometimes keys are going to be
deleted from our cache and as a result
we have to no longer consider them for
eviction so that's pretty easy we just
go ahead and find that key in our hash
map we would then go ahead and basically
remove it from our doubly linked list by
going ahead and doing the delete method
and then finally we would remove that
key from our hash map so yeah we're
basically taking the previous element of
the node to be deleted we're setting the
next attribute of that previous element
to the next attribute of to delete and
then also basically doing the same thing
with the previous Logic for the next
element but you guys can read the pseudo
code I guess my English isn't working
right now and finally as far as updating
goes all we're going to do is say
if the node basically is already in
there we can delete it from both our
hash map and doubly linked list
add it back into our hash map and then
put it in the proper place of the doubly
linked list which is actually just going
to go ahead and be the Tail easy enough
and then the final thing is that in the
event where there's not enough capacity
in our cache we want to be able to get a
key to evict and all we're going to do
is return the key in the doubly linked
list head so we would just be getting
the value of that node easy enough
alrighty so That's all folks sorry I
wasn't being very articulate today I
don't know why but I just can't seem to
think right now but either way let me
know if this format Works a little bit
better for you in terms of learning I
got a few different requests for
languages and I think at the end of the
day pseudocode probably works because
for a question like this it's not really
important how you implement things
what's more important is that you
understand the underlying
object-oriented design principles and
also the algorithmic concepts anyways
have a good night everyone and I will
see you in the next one